esta vez nicolas sarkozy comparece en el
llamado caso pigmalión ese es el nombre
que tenía la agencia de comunicación que
organizaba los actos de su campaña para
la reelección en el año 2012 pero esta
empresa gastó mucho más dinero del
permitido en la ley de partidos
políticos y para esconderlo tenía una
suerte de contabilidad paralela a través
de la cual emitía facturas falsas que no
iban a nombre de la campaña sino que a
nombre del partido del presidente en esa
época la mp nicolas sarkozy por lo tanto
juzgado por financiamiento ilegal de
campaña se expone un año de cárcel ya
una multa de 3.750 euros el ex
presidente en todo momento dice que no
conocía esta contabilidad paralela pero
que sí sabía que estaba gastando mucho
dinero en su campaña hay que decir que
nicolas sarkozy comparece además con
varios miembros seis miembros del que
fuera su partido la vp y con varios
dirigentes de la empresa pigmalión es
muy probable que la audiencia de hoy se
suspenda ya que dos abogados de los
acusados están enfermos de kobe 19